breaking right now our first look at the
two adults involved in a fatal crash
that killed two toddlers Sunday night in
North Las Vegas Police say Kalia Manning
was driving and smelled of alcohol
officers say ranisa Washington is the
mother of those two children killed and
that she was a passenger in that car
with more on the charges both women are
facing in this violent crash let's head
out to Sasha Loftus in our Newsroom Ryan
and Vanessa at North Las Vegas Police
say the children's mom was riding in the
passenger seat at the time of this crash
she and the driver who was the child's
Aunt according to police both facing
multiple charges the little girls killed
in Sunday's crash three-year-old Taylor
Wilmer and two-year-old Rose Wilner
officers tell us 25-year-old Kalia
Chalet lost control of that car here
near Lone Mountain and Clayton Street
she is facing multiple charges three
counts of DUI resulting in substantially
bodily harm or death two counts of child
neglect and endangerment resulting in
death and officers say renesa Washington
the children's mother who again was
riding in the car at the time of that
crash also faces two child neglect and
endangerment charges now neither child
was wearing age appropriate safety
restraints according to police I spoke
with a family member of the two girls
tonight who is urging others to keep
their kids safe in the car we'll have
more on that coming up tonight at 11.
reporting live in The Newsroom Sasha
Loftus 8 News Now